welcome back to the wallet podcast i'm
james marshall and this episode is
brought to you by our awesome
partners firstly straight face raisers
who have been satisfying our listeners
who have taken the 50 off discount and
given the sharpest five blade razor a go
wow well done to you guys
if you're in need of a new razor make
sure you head over to wallet.com
click the straight face logo and receive
your discount also todd's racing have
helped the podcast out massively
just because regan todd is an absolute
lad so if you're a lad or even if you're
not
go give todd's racing a follow on
facebook or twitter that'd be much
appreciated
also if you're keen to help the podcast
directly go and get yourself some water
let coffee
some super popular merch or some pure
sports cbd and all the information is on
waterlab.com anyway let's get to this
episode today let's roll them through
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so anyway i've got a star started panel
on to select the site
starting with an nrl guru and a super
rugby star
jackson garden bishop welcome jacko says
dara good to be back
great to have you back you shared a lot
of great knowledge in the rugby union
side so looking forward to
it being switched over and sharing your
knowledge in the league with the league
boys yeah man another enjoyable side to
pick um
some players that i wish i picked in my
team that the other boys selected as
well so
looking forward to the debate ha ha
can't wait the next guest
he is a hurricane's legend and the man
known for his chat
chippy's chat it is the great liam
mitchell welcome chip
thanks jimmy what an honor mate
what are you going to add to the panel
today probably my lack of
nrl uh knowledge
you're just coming in from a pure
pundit's point of view aren't you just
you're a keyboard warrior coming in to
just share your
opinion
speaking of warriors though we've got a
code hopping
expert who's come on to share his
genuine league knowledge
it is the warriors star and now he's
carrying it up in the wellington club
scene it is charlie garb welcome brother
well thank you long time listener
right what
what are you gonna what are you gonna
add to the panel today i'm looking
forward to it
ah i don't know uh probably not too much
we'll see how it goes
surely a little bit of insight to the to
the league boys that you've played with
over the years yeah yeah probably some
insight into them but i'm not too sure
about the
positional play in union so we'll just
play it as we go
oh mate between us i think we might be
able to come up with a pretty good
team okay anyway but the t the teams are
all in
um we've all had a good look at each
other's teams there was some tough
decisions
um the rules are going to be obviously
because
it's hard going from league to rugby uh
the scrums will be golden oldie scrum so
uncontested scrums um line outs will be
as normal but this side will get 12
months to prepare for
a super rugby trans tasman so they've
got a pretty decent preseason to
learn the ins and outs of rugby unions
so
i think they're going to put a pretty
strong side in to be playing in this
super rugby trans tasman next year and
the rules for us you get one power play
um
other than that it's majority rules
power play means that your guy
will be selected in that spot and his
name will be on the back of
that numbered jersey and they'll be
going for sale again so go get yourself
a
what a lad super rugby league jersey
oh they sold actually really well way
better than the merch so
um hence why we're here doing it again
to try and make it back but
we will start off at fullback okay
three guys have gone for tommy turbo
i've obviously gone ponga so i'm going
to give you my reasons in a minute but
you've got to convince us that it
shouldn't be turbo that's true
so you you've all gone turbo this is why
i don't think turbo should be at full
back i i think he's a
dead set certainty to be in the squad
because he is on absolute fire he's
carving up the nrl at the moment
but my concerns with him at fullback is
his kicking game
not sure if anyone can convince me he is
a great kicker of the ball
i feel like teams will be able to trap
him back there so i've gone for ponga
because of his kicking game i think
that's going to be the difference
between him and
turbo very good under the high ball he's
his counter-attack is obviously electric
footwork you don't want to be
um sending up a jagged defensive line
with ponger back there his footwork will
cut holes
and i think he'd be comfortable slotting
it at first receiver
um playing a two-sided playmaker sort of
role if need be
they're my reasons and that's why i
think he should be selected ahead of
turbo
if i changed anyone's mind
not for me it's not really mine mate
maybe only because of the kicking but
apart from that only like months only
the kicking is a huge part of the game
but i think it'd be more effective at
center you see him at center
for new south wales um he's really good
decision maker
whether to hit the short or long ball
things like that he's a great passer
and you let him get on the outside geez
he is dangerous but
i can see why he played him at fullback
but
i do consider him at at center as well
but
just the way all teams play with 10 and
15 and the two
playmaker roles i feel like he'll get
his hands on the ball a lot more
in general play do you want him that
close to the rack but what's that like
oh he'd be behind that second group of
fours wouldn't he well would he
most of the time okay fair enough
he doesn't mind a head up as well no he
does not
well we did select jordy barrett at
fullback for the league side
pretty much because he is turbo junior
so
um it's only fitting that he goes to
fullback for
the union side so the first man selected
in the woodland side
is tom trevoyevich welcome tom
live cross to tom
get his live reaction where's celisi to
do an impression
okay the next one uh 14
right wing two guys have gone roger two
of us a sheck
who we're gonna see in union shortly so
we'll get a real good glimpse
um jacko's gone teddy james sudesco
one of the games greats and lane
mitchell you've gone latrell
who most guys have got in the midfield
but
at the moment it's going to be rts
unless jaco or
chippy can convince us otherwise
jaco you start teddy oh i just had to
have him in the team
and i wanted turbo 15 that's the only
reason yeah he's just dangerous it's
hard to argue against rts though because
he's going to be a gun right winger
um in union probably next year but yeah
couldn't have today's go out of the 15
really
fair enough he is a gun i i did find it
hard to leave out but
um just couldn't find room for him for
me
what about you chip i just yeah i had
roger at
center so i went to trial on the wing
just a big strong finisher um that's
pretty much where i went from i just
needed him in the team somewhere
so you both sound pretty happy to have
rts
as our right winger yeah i'll take him
yeah nice safe rts is
in congratulations roger
looking forward to seeing you play
playing the 15-man code shortly okay 13.
this is going to be tough all right
turbo he's gone
jaco you had gutho chippy head roger
he's gone and gubby had latrell who two
guys have at 12 so
what do we do here hey what have we do
there
you need to think wisely about it
because i might be using my power play
later on
so okay so who is it
out of because right here gone correct
so it's out of gutho
or latrell but hang on we can go to our
12 we can go to our midfield combo here
so we've got whiten luai
latrella trowel at 12 so latrell's one
of our midfielders it's just who he
partners with so we could go with the
latrell
gatho combo jekyll you can talk about
that one
or chip you can talk about the luau
la trail combo and gabby you can go
um white and latrell i'll speak on
guthrie
okay yeah sweet no i just um
cathode is a very smart player i think
at the
the back for parameter he's not like the
game-breaking full-backs that
um all the other teams have but he's
always sort of um in the attacking play
at the right end um very good defender i
think he's smart and behind there as
well so i thought
i thought he'd be a good link i was
there i had latrobe 12
who's the power dude and then i thought
guthu would be sort of that good glue
between him and
the guys outside um conrad smith liked
gcms
yes snakey-esque okay i like it
and obviously latrell's big left foot oh
that'll come in handy
and i'd imagine you get some pretty good
guaranteed gain line off
launchers with the ability to play out
at the back as well so i do like latrell
at 12.
um the other two have gone a trail at
13.
um gabby white and at 12 also like this
one so looking forward to hearing it
yeah i wasn't i wasn't um too fast
whether they were 12 or 13 but i think
they're a good combo
um wyden obviously uh um
a natural center but he's playing in the
halves now and got
um dell em there even though the raiders
are going pretty clucks this year
i think um jack white and still if he
was playing cena he'd be the best center
um not trail
everyone knows the trail i think he's
he's um
he's a game breaker there's no one
really you know
he he beats anyone one-on-one so um i
don't know i just think jack white and
that at 12 was good to get the picking
option i
don't i just remember when the all
blacks they have bowdoin and um
dan carter at 10 and 12. they're both
kicking options but jack white is a real
good running option too and he hits
no one hits harder than him in the backs
so i just reckon that
they compliment each other well but i'm
not too fussed as long as uh jack white
is in there somewhere
jeez i like that you've sold me up there
white and train no one hits harder than
oh geez i remember nani telling me that
actually that white and was
a real good header like he remembered
him playing at a young age or something
and he was just smoking guys
he's a [ __ ] big dude is he yeah it
looks like a second row out there
what about you chip last one lui you've
gone for the
double playmaker the smaller guy
defensively not as strong
but light it up on attack so more than
like
more the lower clary combo rather than
the 12 13. i'm happy with roger at 13
but
i've sort of gone lower just out the
back of the um out the back of
the one of the group of fords there just
good organizer ken kirk also can run so
i sort of went that lower cleary combo
rather than the
lower midfielder but yeah i like his
kicking game as well
and i like how he just if he sees the
picture he takes it you know yeah
i think it would go good maybe
wow three great options
i'm potentially leaning towards white
and after those
sales points but i do like that
big hitting the biggest trail at 12 but
um i'd be happy to push him
you can out one them around i'm not too
fussed um
i don't know it's not my teammates it is
your team
it's a quarter of your team
what about you man we gotta find the
best option what about you
jacko i did enjoy charlie's
whiten argument really open to a power
play this one if anyone wants to take it
yeah i'll probably play white in it at
um 12.
congratulations you two men they'll be
proud jackie boy
big day for them okay left wing
two guys have gone edo carr the fox the
fastest man on the earth
jaco you have gone daniel tupo
daniel
we've got to try and convince one guy to
change their edo car
opinion um uh i've thought about
um car but i just thought it was a bit
of a one-trick pony real quick
but i think you need a bit but more than
that when you're playing union
i think you need a bit of size when
you're on the wing quite often your
first phase kept ball carrier
and you need to be solid defensively so
i like daniel super i think he's
unreal at the edge of the roosters um
and i think he'd be a dangerous strike
option first phase
offset piece very nice like that
okay i've gone valentine homes mate
speaking of first phase strikes jeez
imagine valentine's holmes coming down
your channel
straight to the winger he is electric
hard man to tackle
but what i think he's better about the
other two car
and dantupo's his ability to kick
and catch i mean under the high ball i
mean they're all pretty good under the
high ball but
um valentine holmes is i'd be
comfortable him getting up under
anything
and as the kicking option he has for
when teams try and pepper us in the
backfield
which a lot of teams will will do
against this league side i'd imagine so
i feel like we need to prepare a little
bit better especially with turbo back
there
um he might be looking for valentine
holmes to bail him out a few times to
to get his what he got what a 50 meter
drop goal the other day mate he can kick
he
he can kick from anywhere
and he's a good defender so um he's
obviously had experience
swapping codes as well he's played nfl
so
it's nothing new to him trying to pick
up a new sport so i feel like he'd adapt
really well to it but
um obviously you guys have both chosen
edo cartoon forward so
might i say any have we convinced cnbs
i just i like the way the fox chases
kicks kick chase
and you know and i don't mind him just
being an adam out speedster on that wing
just
finishing tries and i don't mind how he
um starts off a few sets as well so
grunty does so i think he's more than
just a one-trick pony there jaco
yeah i i think he can he can carry him
hey man i'm trying to sell daniel here
so you two are convinced jesus scored
some trials too
no changes from you too i feel like
daniel
didn't get there thanks gabby
did it change your vote though no
no you lost me from 50 hours
well if we're down by two we do
okay
yeah true okay congratulations to the
fox
now the next one at 10 usually one of
the toughest positions to pick but we
have
all agreed potentially the best player
in the game at the moment or
arguably two behind turbo probably
um nathan cleary
is at 10 everyone's picked him
anyone want to go into reasons why they
picked them a bit of a no-brainer but
yeah no-brainer i just can't believe
that he's 23 or 24.
yeah crazy eh so good oh man turbo both
younger than me and they're both two of
my favorite players now it's been weird
most guys are younger than you aren't
they yeah
hey man i'm like halfway
like the middle man
you're the
yeah okay next one this is our first 50
50 split
me and jacko have both gone harry grant
the wizard
and gabby and chip have both gone for
damien cook
the speedster jacko you want to sell the
harry grant dream for the boys
i just like the way he plays i like uh
um
he's quite confrontational he loves
getting out from the ruck when they when
there's quick ball
um and not afraid to take the line on
uh and he also distributes well when
when it when
cam monster and jerome hughes won it so
i think he's got a pretty good all-round
game um he hasn't had to kick much
for the storm so i haven't seen much of
that but i'm sure he can
yeah i feel like he'd probably kick the
ball better than damien cook
yeah it's hard to know both of them have
kicking halves and it seems so
i've just seen harry grant do some box
kicks at training and
wow i saw that on the instagram story
the other day actually
okay melbourne
okay who wants to sell the damon cook
dream
chippy go on yeah i've just gone cooked
i've gone damien cook because
he just seems a little bit nippy and a
little bit faster i'm not sure if it's
like if it is right or not with the
stats i've gone harry grant on the bench
purely because of what jackson said i
just wanted to come on and finish that
last 20 run a bit more in the last sort
of 2030 where
i want um damian cook just getting to
the right quicker and
letting clary go loose let that back
line loose rather than running it too
much at the start so
that's what i've got starting grunt off
on the bench
i've sort of swapped them around so i've
got it me and jacko both got cook
off the bench but pretty much for those
reasons i feel like cook would be more
of the runner he'd be quick to the ball
he'd get that ball away really quickly
obviously he's he's incredibly fast and
a dangerous run around the fringes where
i feel like
harry grant would probably be a bit more
controlled with um with his past running
game and
defense to start the game so um what
about you gabby anything to add there
yeah i think um if i had my time to get
up who
would go grant at nine
that's damn good honesty from you so
harry grant has earned congratulations
to harry
and his family um number eight
gecko me and you are similar we're on
the same page a lot we've both gone for
feta
big david fafeta absolute beast
chippy you've gone a loose one here
katoni stags i didn't think about too
many
backs as becoming forwards but i'm
looking forward to hearing that and
gabby
the big cacao the beast
take us away chips try and convince us
one of us need to change our vote
i've got a real loosener um something
different i think
he sort of reminds me of what um arty
would audi would be like if he played
league on the edges there he's got good
skills
if you were to play him on an edge in
that sort of a one three three one shape
he'd be good on an edge and he'd also be
good through the middle taking on your
props and stuff
i think his skill set and that would
help that and he's also
a powerful runner so wherever on the
field he's running he's not going to be
he's not going to be at a loss yeah off
the back of the scrum as well i reckon
it'd be dangerous
yeah so i've gone home not the worst
chap i like it
gabby cacao yeah um
now i've just always liked him i i think
it'd be a good day just
he's very one-on-one
i think like um off the back of a scrum
it'd be um it'll take more than the
flanker and half back to um
do the damage to him so i think it'd be
good good on that
and then what um chipper said about that
one three three one which i'm not too
familiar with but
i'm guessing i could be the one on the
edge and you know i wouldn't want to be
the one marking up on them but
the feet are equally the same so um
yeah no hard feelings if you go off the
feet i just think
um key cow is equally as damaging with
the ball
um any any hits hard to again oh
he's tried to sell the old hit harder
you almost got me it's harder than
anyone
it's hard in the game
well i agree with both of you i think
they're all good options but i just feel
like for feta is just
bigger and stronger and potentially
faster maybe not faster than stags but
um he's just upper level on all of them
and
sort of those tackle breaking abilities
and he's just a freak i reckon what
about you jacko
yeah i can't sway from fifido i mean he
played toys with players
um a lot of the time um see some of
those early rounds when he was just
tapping and going from 10 out and sort
of just swatting three guys away and
putting the ball down yeah i wouldn't
want that coming around at me from
number eight off the back of a scrum no
pass i'm defending in the wide channel
asap
i'm blind there
yeah but like you say he does make it
men against boys sometimes in the nrl so
um i'd be looking forward to seeing him
play in super ugly trans tasman for the
willard league side so congratulations
to
david fafeta and his family
seven this is a good one because we've
all gone separate
ones so i've gone cameron murray jaco
you've got angus crichton
chippy you've got another back you love
the backs and the forwards connor watson
and gabby you've gone brandon smith the
cheese
all good options looking forward to
hearing about them all start with you
connor watson lam mitchell yeah i was
struggling to find a seven i um
i did i've gone murray on my [ __ ] as
well who i also wouldn't mind starting
but i think he's a
from what i've seen on his social media
he looks like it's pretty stacked dude
so
it looks sort of big enough he sort of
gives me that duplica
vibe about him um he seems like he'll be
a nugget over the ball
he um goes hard as well which good
sevens do
heaps of tackles heaps of carries in
that so yeah i sort of went for an
explosive dude there
nice good argument like it jaco
angus chryson um tough as hell
he's a workhorse he always he plays 80
every week
um tons of carries tons of tackles
and yeah i just think he's that that
tough seven that we wanted outside
um cut his finger off so that he could
keep playing league so yeah i think he'd
do anything for the boys
um nice i've got him at six to be fair
i know i know he's got a lot of rugby
union background he's a
australian schoolboy star so um
no problems with him crossing codes so
um i agree with a lot of your points
there but i've i've found a place for
him at blindside flanker i've gone
cameron murray
who mate massive fan of cam murray
fast strong tough and he just his body
shape just looks like he'd be really
niggly over the ball he's got that sort
of
hunch in his back and he's relatively
short and
well i feel like he would be the jackal
king out of the nrl so
for that those are the reasons i've gone
camera absolute workhorse he can he can
he makes 50 tackles i mean
works no issues for him he's definitely
my seven but
uh one more you've gone the cheese guppy
who everyone else has gone at hooker so
convince us to get him to seven yeah i
think um i think that jesus too small
parker i got him at
um seven he's just 100 miles an hour
from the get-go
um no one has had it
he no he just
he he's a real dog on the field you know
he's got there see you next tuesday in
them and
he's you know you i don't know he's just
like that seven that every rock could be
in your face
um over the ball you know he's
i don't know i thought he was a
no-brainer
[Music]
mate like to be fair if three of us
didn't have him at hookah
i reckon he would be our seven after
that right
he needs to be in the team somewhere i
agree with all those points
um golden oldies might save him with his
weight um
at hookah so we we should still get the
benefit of having him on the field even
if he's at hooker
on the edge again and maybe a one three
three one but
it's going to happen boys
power play
there's something else congratulations
to cam
murray and his family okay six
christ in it sex for me
yeah i saw her um for feta
chippy he's on the team and tarek sims
oh looking forward to hearing this one
christ and i've gone christian for the
reasons we've already talked about
um gabby tarek sims talk to me
yeah tarik sims but i feel like all our
ball carriers at the moment our fords
are
you know they got late for work and
offload and stuff like that maybe that's
not ideal when you're looking to clean
out
so eric sims is that guy you go to the
set off he's uh no nonsense
you know he he's a rock surrounded by
rock stars so i think
i think every team needs that little guy
and um
yeah i don't know i i could be sold on
other ones but i think
he'd be a good six you know he's just
he's just no nonsense
got a bit of ethan black at her about
him oh mate if i if you're talking
either blackhead i'm signing
jimmy's favorite player player how good
is it
you've done your research who to compare
players to
right i'm i'm happy but i mean
jaco you've obviously got crichton you
had him at seven
and papalia six so you've got options to
either go either of those two now off
yeah when crichton wasn't seven i'd
probably want him to be six
i think he fits a similar mode to what
you're talking to with tarik sims as
well
like i think he does have that attacking
upside but i still think at the end of
the day he's uh he's
like he can be a hit man he can be the
enforcer we want him to be
um and he probably won't have to be much
else because we've got that much razzle
around the rest of the board pack so
he's sort of ethan blackout alike as
well isn't he
yeah if i was going to compare him to
anyone blackhead probably
okay okay
congratulations angus you are at
blindside with two votes
okay at five
we've got two tino's faster malawi
myself and guppy have him um ryan
madison for jacko
good shout out and isaiah
yao for you chip i actually want um big
nelson at five as my big tight headlock
if we're gonna get specific on it but
yeah i don't even know what that means
no
okay i also agree i think he's
definitely a tight headlock
um yeah that's the thing it should be
yeah i didn't know it was five
so nelson is at five because we've all
got nelson he's two meters
he was a rugby union star like we said
like he can hit
he can carry or he'd be a tough man in
that pack
potentially the biggest hitter right
gabby i don't know he'd be up there
and he would be a great man's heavier
behind in the scrum wouldn't he chip
you tell me about that not sure well
i'd hope so i've never played prop but
no but you know how important it is
yeah wow all um tyrell cares about us
how heavy you are so
if he's a heavy dude he'd be sweet well
he's very heavy how heavy is he guppy
uh you know he'd be um a buck 20
buck 30 easy i couldn't believe he was
two meters
i thought he was shorter than that but
that's massive
you got a wide screen tv
i'm not my laptop
micro vision
okay now we'll get to the loose headlock
sorry chip
number four two of us have tino
jaco has madison ryan madison and chippy
isaiah yao who wants to try and convince
myself or gabby to go away from tino who
is
amita 97 which i couldn't believe either
i thought he was
way more of a nugget but he is a big boy
yeah i've gone isaiah purely on his
ball play i like him at the back playing
at the back of
stuff and i think he's a workhorse as
well so yeah that's pretty much where
i've got him
he's actually like if you could go like
for like he is you
in league like you and him are very
similar
yeah work great right okay
no if you shave your head a bit shorter
jesus
would get confused i've got him
i like the way he plays yeah now fair
enough no doubt he's the glue he's the
key to that
panther's teammate jacko um
i've got medicine obviously probably the
opposite of chippy just another worker
um i think nelson will be there ball
playing offloading
lock of the two so i think mata will be
i'm a good worker for us also he
measures on
a meter 98 actually so no he's not it's
a yeah
you can't be making up stats to get him
from the team
but i i think mata was quite restly with
his offload and stuff
you you have him a worker i'm a little
bit worried about it he won't be his he
won't be
with me as a tech coach yeah joe's one
on
six i think yeah you're right 195
centimeters yeah that's why i just
went for um tino i thought those two
centimeters
which i couldn't believe that he was
taller than him might be andy come line
up time for
inexperience um line outside but
did anyone change their opinions or
a few people i'm going to power play
that i think jabber go on give us
that is against two votes that's a
strong power play you've used
before tino is hard done by but
congratulations to he is very hard done
by there
but maybe we'll find a spot for him in
the bench
and it will definitely help me out with
spelling on the back of the shirts
which is always handy so thanks
we've gone from a thousand letters to
three very good
okay number three three of us have gone
for
the kiwi legend jason talmalolo
and leah mitchell you have gone for
papalee yeah i'm happy with um
as well i just i really struggled with
the front rows
fair enough it is hard when when you're
thinking scrums and things like that
you'd be crazy not to have tao malolo as
a
as a prop gee whiz
okay congratulations to tal malolo
um hookah three of us have the cheese
and gabby
you've gone for papalee which one are we
talking here
um josh josh yeah yeah because i
obviously had things at seven
yeah which i think is his preferred
position um
[Music]
cheese out cheese that too and i'll have
um papa somewhere
okay brandon smith congratulations
i guess the thing about him is he is a
very good line-out thrower
and he looks like not so much now but
when dane coles was younger
him and dane coles were identical it was
it's weird how much
they looked alike cosy's obviously aged
yeah the haircut when kelsey had his
longer hair
but he is and khalsi started off as a
small hooker too like he was under 100
kgs
um i think we could get the cheese
because he's playing big minutes at
hookah he's
he's shredding but um once we get him
12 months into davey gray's
size program i feel like we could get
him to one ten clicks easy and
throwing darts like like no one else
looking forward to seeing where we can
take the site
brandon smith right on
okay last position in the starting
lineup we've all gone
the big pain huss at prop
and what a beast he is except for gabby
you've gone junior paulo
yeah because um remember a couple of
years ago he played a union game over
here on
and he played pro so he's got experience
there
um that's the only reason i picked them
there
um payne house is good too but i think
he'd be a good uh
a good lucy off the bench oh okay
uh unlucky what did he play a game for
club club rugby lovely game we got a
i think you gotta find about 20 grand oh
come on what for playing union
how much do you find something like 20k
somewhere
that's a massive thing if he's not
starting he's got to be on the team for
that
yeah all right i just checked and he's
not actually on my bench but
i'm happy to have him
and i mean the thing with props is it's
sort of like a 50 30 split these days
with game time so
it's not a huge difference whether
you're starting or coming off the bench
you're going to play
a massive role in this side especially
when we're coming up against the kiwi
sides and
super rugby trans tasman it's going to
be hard fast games
so we're going to have to have every one
of our members
right on point so this is when the bench
come in
our impact shall we call them just to
get some
clear messages across the team early on
but we'll start with number 16 at hooker
we've all gone separate ones so i've
gone
jake trevor it should be good to have
him there with his brother um
jaco you've gone jazz tavanga chippy
kenny bromwich
and gabby uh for noah blake
so um jaco you start with jazz tavanga
um i love the way he comes off the bench
for the warriors i think he always
whenever he comes on he sparks boys up
um
gets into his work in the middle and i
think he'll do the same
out on the edge and and the 15 aside
game i think he's
got good skills got good enough skills
because he plays lock and league every
now and then
and also hooker as well so he's got the
skills to throw
and um throw a catch and pass on on
on the edge as well so that's why i
picked him as impact hooker
fair enough it's a good good sales point
line out throwing happy
as happy as i'm with cheese
[Laughter]
fear okay kenny bromwich this one was a
late change from you chippy you saw
something in him
late change yeah i like his footwork and
he's got a similar
build to cause he's so let's practice
what i've got
we're just trying to get kelsey
yeah i just want a team of cause and
i'll be happy gabby
now the nrl guru what have you got for
us
uh i went for no black i feel like in i
don't know in union
the front row four they should be
playing in the middle and rugby league
you know playing tough and
doing their job if you know if we've got
a team of causes then there's
quite a few guys that want to score
trice but
um so i think for noah flake you know
he's he's big
he's scary um he's got a good tip on
um good pass which would equate to a
good throw-in
um and yeah he's
i don't know he's just that guy that you
want to uh
next to you know when uh when shit's
going down
but and that's not just dankos because
i'm a big fan of it
yeah fair enough because we obviously
two guys
myself and you jacko have phenol black
at prop in our reserve
so um hear what you say there gabby
definitely want him in my side but
whether we lock him in at hooker or go
prop
i'm open has anyone got a power play
left they want to use it on a hooker i
don't know
oh jake trevorvich i haven't even got to
my one
now jake is tough he is he would be your
sort of glue can ball play
great line out thrower playing with his
brother they've got a great combination
and now that he's been selected at
fullback that's going to be handy
like you guys said sniffing around that
second pod
the girbo turbo balls going inside
outside again like they do for manly so
um very dangerous coming off the bench
for the sort of last
30 20 minutes depending how long um the
cheese lasts but
um yeah like i said impact and just
a bit of grit you know um pretty keen to
have on my side but
all very split opinions and i liked
everyone's points there
i've got jake at prop yeah so i'm happy
to have him on my team as well but
especially with the golden oldies scrubs
so we might as well move on to our props
before we lock them in so we can sort of
lock them in as a three
because a lot of them are sort of
crossed over we've got fenugreek
and papalie
he's made it so um do we need to find
two more props
well we need to choose two props out of
uh out of these four
fenugreek papali
paulo and trevorvich or either of them
could go hooker we've basically got four
to go into
three if we're going on the double votes
like papa lee needs to be there
somewhere off the bench
yeah yeah yeah i think he has to be
there
the only reason i'd go against a prop
because he's
he's small yeah i agree i think he's a
hooker i don't know like you only
like he's a small body mm-hmm like and
you might like he can hit hard i think
he'll be wrong he can hit him
he's in but you might be able to shift
them you know like
shift them around around the malls and
that sort of thing yeah whereas
if there's vanilla black standing there
i might not hit that mall you know yeah
yeah
you're banging i don't think he's a prop
to be fair but i see him as
potentially a hooker but fenugreek and
paulo papalee those three looking for
or does someone see one of them as a
hooker i like fernando blake as a prop
yep okay fenora blake is in as a prop he
had
um had enough votes there he's earned
congratulations
uh so the next prop would be out of
papali
or paulo so paulo we sort of gave him a
fake promise that would pick him because
he
his commitment to union um who's going
to have the hard conversation with him
one-on-one if he ends up missing out
not me liam i look up my vote
[Laughter]
so paulo's in so that means he could be
our hooker
if we see him fit as a hooker yeah i'd
love to see that but it's up to that's
up to the guys you know if they want to
see it
i'm happy to see that as well i need him
i need him on the field
last
me and jaco have him on the bench so it
is only fair okay he's in
no concerns and he's a great line-up
throw and he hits hard
harder than anyone okay 19.
we got two tohu harris that's a nice
option
angus crichton he's already gone and
paseka
talk to me about this guy um gabby i
didn't see this one
coming oh just i've been to the airport
a few times and seen like the south
african teams
and they're just real big guys and he
kind of fits that mould
he's just a big unit um
runs hard just runs straight plays tight
um we've got a lot of guys that play
pretty loose so
i reckon you'd bring him on he'd be in
that brad meeker mould
nice comparison throwback
shout out to brad now you're listening
to him
and we've still actually to be fair
we've still got a couple of unlucky
locks who missed out on the starting
lineup tino in particular
and ryan madison oh yeah i'm happy to
see tina on the bench
yeah yeah i feel like i feel like he's
unlucky but
tohu harris i mean talk about it i'll be
upset
who's gone um well you've got to you're
the only one who can do this because
you're the power play only one left i do
gabby has one too don't he yeah gabby
says forgot
all right i got one i think
oh yeah yeah so we're locking in um
unless
give us your rabbits
so tino's in yeah jacko
so who will we filthy yeah okay number
20
reserve loose ford so i've gone
victor radley imagine him coming off
your bench if you want
if you want energy this man is coming on
with
abundance of it bringing all sorts of
physicality
i'll get him on my bench two guys have
got cam murray who's already made the
squad but a couple of you guys missed
out
um and crichton so a few have already
made the squad
but the options are sort of uh cacao
watson stags
tarik sims papa lee are you thinking
rally to cover
six seven and eight or i think would
do some shifting um i think it'd be a
genuine sort of
seven or six and just cover sort of
dino covering lock and he could
potentially
who's um or crichton we could move
christ into eight
and have a couple of features with cam
murray and um
radley but i i see what you're saying
chip does
a little bit of the same same with cam
murray but victor
you i know you love victor the inflictor
i love victor
i'm surprised he wasn't in your sight
and captain
yeah i actually forgot about him to be
fair
yeah out of sight out of mind that sort
of thing he hasn't been playing for a
while so
why haven't somebody got stood down for
pissing up on a plane or something is
that true or
oh then he he got put on report
five times in one game when the rules
were given
five times in 20 minutes he was totally
in one so we'll have to
have a few mental skills sessions with
him early doors but
i think if we can control that
aggression
we could get him right on bringing some
real physicality
off the bench but anyone disagree with
that
or anyone they want to propose
yeah i'll go i'll go a bigger body like
because angus cried
is not on the team eh yes he's at um six
keep up
all right um i'd have a bigger body
there then
um radley in there i feel like radley
and um cameron murray
and those guys there they play forwards
and
league but i think they'll be more of a
back like
they probably played backs at school
didn't murray play um
wasn't he didn't he come from union he
did
crichton was a midfielder as well yeah
yeah those guys are
he's a back so i don't know just
it's but different arrogantly you have a
10 meter run up so
it's more high speed and that sort of
thing but that close contact i reckon
you need a bigger body
okay i'd go um i wouldn't have them
there
who are you going how would you prefer
would you prefer tohu harris
i'd prefer tony harris definitely we
have crichton covering seven
yeah yeah peacock vibe
across in there cover seven if you have
to
yeah click seven there and just left and
right
yeah left and right harris would be
like he's leaving him out would be like
leaving rick's milk out you know just
because
there's other good yeah well you've got
your wish
gecko i'll power player i'll power
player he was in
anyway but he's getting doubled
[Music]
i've got to use i'm not going to waste
on outside back oh
tohu harris great to have you in the
squad looking forward to working with
you
um 21 has been all but confirmed
damien cook unless gabby you've got
lui at halfback interesting
yeah no i don't want him there anymore
um
cook cooker's in didn't think about it
that was easy we sort of talked about
that
speed and all the sparky brings off the
bench 22 this is where it gets
interesting
um like you said gabby you've gone for
cam murray
at reserve inside back interesting
um chippy monster i was really tossing
up between munster
uh jaco you've gone ponger still a
little bit gutted he missed out on my
starting squad
i went for sean johnson i just feel like
i'd like to see him at 10 or even full
back
just his timing his kicking game
pass being able to screw up defenders i
feel like he'd go really well but
happy to hear the other guy's arguments
because i mean ponga was in my starting
lineup
so well change of um i'm going with
chippy with monster
yeah um he's a competitor um he's an
option for everything
yeah i i like monster there
yeah i like monster there too it was a
really tough one but i like his i like
his versatility
cover 10 probably 12 15. yeah
can cap can run good organizer
not sure about his goal kicking in the
clutch but if we if clary's still on
yeah happy day that's true
and he seems like an absolute lad oh
teddy black's just ripping his jersey
everywhere shout out to oates um
jacko ponga i i just think he's
one would be one of the best teams at
all one of the best fullbacks
um to cross over um obviously he came
through with union
um i'm pretty sure he played 10 for his
school um before he got picked up
and obviously he's been a gun fullback
now for the last few years in league so
i think he could cover both as good as
anyone hey
where was that when we were picking our
starting fallback
i like the fact that he could cover both
yeah
david we're not covering both there
could you see him on the wing
like we could potentially go ponga
outside
reserve and monster potentially if
that's what we wanted to do
only other guys we've got less left uh
who's our wingers we've our wingers are
eddocar and roger
so the guys we've got left teddy
saab sivo
holmes so
a couple of loose options i'll be
nervous about i'll be nervous about
midfield cover
if we went monster ponga yeah i feel
like would
um chuck rts into 13 and i reckon he'd
be comfortable there
he's potentially going to play there
when he comes over to you
yeah so i feel like he would be in cover
munster would be our 12 cover um
and ponga outside backs and
potentially 10 so i'm not yeah whether
we would need months to end ponga yeah i
hear you
i like saab i like sub off the benches
close to starting for me but
so fast so so big but
not sure what you guys thought on that
well that too
now that turbo's there geez he's
improved tenfold so
um and and league at the moment so
turbo's at fullbacks they
keep the combination i see what you're
doing there chap you're a smart man
i can't forgive him for the start of the
year yeah
me me though he was my cash
oh i've still got him
patience um gabby talk to me about siva
i don't know
he's a he's a big body he's fast
he probably doesn't have uh the skills
that those other guys have or maybe
what saab has but i don't know he's a
good finisher
bring him on and you know put the
blowout and just keep throwing him out
but
i don't know i i'm not too uh too fussed
about the bench
i feel like he would go pretty good to
be fair be um
he'd be pretty tough to tackle but
whether we can find better did you have
him on the bench though no probably not
i feel like he's either the starting
maybe he's starter yeah all right so i
like the monster ponga combo
yeah they're not 42 only person
who misses out here which is a bit of a
travesty is
james tedesco arguably being the best
player
in the game for the last uh
two or three years um struggling a
little bit with the roosters at the
moment but
he's still an absolutely genuine leaguer
yeah that's sort of why he didn't pick
him to start i feel like
couldn't really find a position for him
his lack of kicking
his i mean his goal kicking him on the
wing yeah
would you rather pong a covering wing or
teddy
pogba purely for his versatility okay
monster and pogba start i'd say teddy
yeah
fair enough everyone happy monster and
ponga
speak now yup couple of nice names on
the back of a jersey too
they'll go for plenty at the end yeah
just decide deciding what one
yeah i mean tedesco maybe
20 24th man
james sudesco could cover in traveling
reserve 22
traveling reserves who who's the other
one would need uh
which ford's missed out you've got to
take radley as your trailer yeah
it'll be radley yeah you need him on
sunday okay victor
and teddy they're in our squad they're
traveling
gee whiz that's a good sight boys man
we've come up with
a side which i how do you reckon that
would go against um
in super rugby trans tasman with a year
build up
not bad not bad tough in the aussie team
the gold knot is they're not as scrums
and they weren't all their own lineups
they'd be
um maybe no more either how hard is it
to learn
like a line out chippy like in 12 months
how tough of a skill is that from
someone who's got no idea about line
outs
like you'd be able to figure out the
basics but i don't think you compete
with
the super team fair enough and no way
it's a tough game
not waiting in line and the morning it's
the mauling and stuff that would kill
the american
that's true like the rocks and stuff
is that tough to transition into yeah
just i
i feel like it's a combination of
everything like um
you're playing off it's so flat like
you're not used to taking a carry and
then
you know like and then getting tackled
after 30 centimeters it's just
yeah the whole thing's hard like when
even on defense when you're looking up
the pictures you're seeing are way
different like you're not seeing like
a guy with a with a lead and a back door
you're seeing like a
you know like four-fourths and you don't
really know which one's getting the ball
and then they've got a back door and
then 20 meters away there's another pod
like it's it's just a completely
different
picture and i think yeah i don't reckon
i'd get it in the in a year that i don't
think they could compete
even though physically that wouldn't be
a problem and that'd be good to watch
but
just i just i don't know you know what
americans easier to transition would it
be easier to go from union to league or
league to union
it'd be easier to go from oh probably
it depends i think if you're a back you
could probably go from
league to union maybe not as first five
but you know the outside back midfielder
but probably equally probably as a
fourth will be easier to go from
union to leg because um it's a bit more
basic it's just
it's more just about um working hard and
you know just going hard and running
tough lines it's just a bit different
what do you have to be fitter for league
league
oh yeah then again like that's not i'm
not i don't know i'm not a
uh i only play nothing with my mates but
speaking of you know guys like nani and
that they were they were they would say
the same
their league is just
at the top level club then
then if it's you're comparing clubs in
new zealand
club rugby has a higher standard than
new zealand club league but um
if you're talking about the top levels
then rugby league you know you cover a
lot more distance so
the fords will be doing you know 9k
games things like that so boy
it's just fought back for back you know
[ __ ] the back and forward would kill you
wouldn't it
yeah yeah yeah i i don't know non-stop
bronco
every you know like unions are hard on
its aspects and
and leagues harder than suspects but um
i think league fitness wise is
tough i feel like the lack of um
stoppages and league
really make it harder compared to union
like especially as a back like you get
when there's a scrum there's a back you
often get two to three
sometimes longer minutes of rest to
recover whereas
in leg there's not really any stoppages
they like they've got
clocks on everything's dropouts and
scrums and the balls in place so much
but
i guess they get their rest briefly
while
um the outside backs take the tough
carries and
they try and get the air in there but um
yeah like you said it
i think it's different would definitely
be tougher um
on the lungs yeah yeah you probably have
to ask someone that's uh
that's played that at top at both levels
but i remember they
i went to like a thing in 2010 and they
were talking about
the ball and play and this was slipped
back then super rugby was something like
21 minutes
of the 80 minutes the ball was in play
um and the nrl at that time was
39 something like that so i think that
makes a bit you know it's double the
amount of time and play
and i think it will be even more yeah
way more now yeah it's like 70. and the
kick battles in union
the fords can just park up in the middle
of the field and just wait for someone
to kick it out
or run it there's no there's no
he's parking up in the middle yeah i
don't know
okay last thing we need to name our
captain for our snapchat
who's our captain going to be name the
squad bro
tommy turbo roger tovaso latrell
mitchell jack whiteon
josh edoka nathan cleary harry grant
david fafeta
cam murray angus crichton nelson azad
yao
jason talmololo brandon smith painthouse
clary for me captain clary
he's definitely my captain and super
coach but
captain to lead the squad i'm happy with
that anyone disagree yeah no
i don't mind captain kerry he's young
he's got plenty of years
lead by example yeah
yeah as a winger you can't really do
that so go go cleary but
then maybe you can be you'll be in the
leadership group he's definitely in the
leadership group
he's a leader isn't he jeez what a lead
he is a lead um cheers boys appreciate
you giving up your time and
helping me select the squad no worries
bro
awesome
yeah that wraps it up what a lad
what a man
[Music]